alright broke people poor people
employee mindset is when you trade your
time for money rich people they don't
trade their time for money
rich people they trade their value for
money and their value can be something
that they do in 20 seconds it can be
something that they do wants and the
values there forever which is called a
passive income so if you're an employee
and you're thinking in terms of trading
your time for money and you go to the
office and you work 9:00 to 5:00 and you
get paid for 9:00 to 5:00 or if you're
an hour extra then you charge over time
for your time you just get out of that
thing keep straight away because it
sucks it stinks it'll keep you broke it
will keep you poor and rather than
thinking I want to get out of that and
become my own boss you're never gonna be
your own boss you're never gonna be your
own boss until you stop thinking like
that now so in your job okay or to your
boss or whoever your manager start
thinking of how can you add more value
to the work place stop trading your time
for money right this second
don't worry about becoming a millionaire
investor because never gonna happen it's
never gonna happen until right now today
you stop this mindset of exchanging time
for money how can you be more valuable
to your boss how can you be more
valuable to your management company
become so good at work they don't
becoming embarrassing for them not to
promote you and give you a bonus become
so good
it becomes embarrassing but they cannot
give you a pay rise and listen any smart
manager may be awesome you'll understand
my boss is different listen any smart
manager any smart and if the managers
giving you a hard time go over the head
because it trust me
you become valuable you can start doing
that kind of thing so that's my advice
you stop dreaming that's it ah you know
one day I'm gonna be this amazing
investor one day I'm gonna be this
business owner you already are a
business owner you already are an
investor right now you're an investor
even if you're not investing into
property you're investing your time and
your energy into stuff you are a
business owner you are an investor right
now you are an entrepreneur maybe an
intrapreneur within a company start
thinking like it's not acting like you
don't be entitled man don't be don't
think um I deserve this just beer until
it's embarrassing the people don't give
you the recognition that he deserves
and if people right now aren't giving
you credibility in your job and your
family in the workplace it's because you
suck want more recognition no just don't
don't demand it with the words become so
valuable that it becomes embarrassing
for the CEO not to want to have a chat
with you that's my message so stop
messing around
stop being broke stop making excuses
stop being entitled start adding value
and by the way this way of thinking is
what makes the world a better place
because the rich if it wasn't for
entrepreneurs the world would be
completely bankrupt if it wasn't for
entrepreneurs why because the definition
of an entrepreneur is someone who adds
value makes the world a better place
then the money follows it's like the bee
that had the honey bee the honey bee
goes into the plant to get pollen to
then make honey because it wants honey
but in doing that it fires out of the
flower the pollen falls down on the
floor and it creates more plants and in
those plants that they keep reproducing
because of the honey bee give us oxygen
and keep the world moving and keep the
world in existence the honey bee is
possibly the most important important
creature on earth because if it wasn't
for the honey bee the world would be
extinct we big sneaked in the same way
you have to be a money B go and get the
money go and get the money going add
value but in doing that it becomes
valuable you're gonna not only make
money for yourself you're gonna make
money for other people you're gonna
leave a legacy you're gonna make the
world a better place so stop moaning and
start making money start adding value
stop being entitled and I'm just sick of
excuses
I'm sick of broke people complaining
rather than just making things better
anyway that's my rant and don't do I
don't even care what you thought about
it maybe this run pissed you off
maybe you think what are you talking
about you see you from a slightly
different perspective listen I've been
poor okay and I've been rich I know
which one I prefer I know which one
impacts more people when I was poor I
wasn't helping anybody when I was poor I
was just trying to help myself I was
like I was like a hungry orphan like I
want food I want but but now now I help
thousands and thousands of people so
actually being poor is actually being
selfish Oh
one's gonna get some dislikes some
dislikes on the video yeah other care do
you like dislike subscribe unsubscribe I
only care about one thing that she
actually going take some action start
getting some results then that gives me
my oxygen is my people
got me in the street and not say summer
I know who you are so I've seen your
videos I don't care about that who will
stop me in the street and say Samuel I'm
financially free because of you that's
what gives me a kick so I don't care
whatever you want to do from now in
terms of this video I just care you guys
actually takes an action and go and
change your life and then just let me be
part the story I'm done